[Music]
but philadelphia really attacking
in the paint
[Applause]
so both teams will catch their breath
middle stage is opening quarter
on tnt
all right so we had a coaches challenge
from brett brown the
wish a whistle initially on joel embiid
it has been overturned
and stan you seem to agree yeah pretty
obvious here smart
initiates a contact and runs into embiid
and the reason brett brown challenges
that even though it would have just been
ball out of bounds to boston seems
inconsequential
but they need joel embiid that would
have been his second foul
that's why brett brown challenges that
and beads off to a great start
interesting though with the celtics brad
stevens as he said with his bench
he told them at the beginning of the
year these are our five best players
the four guys besides tice who started
tonight
and gordon hayward everybody else's job
is to make them better
and he uses them situationally so we
came out of that last time out
simeola was on the floor when brett
brown
brought embiid back simeola immediately